just to go after it I mean the thing
about being an entrepreneur is this it's
just all to you you know a lot of people
like to make excuses I don't have
connections I don't have money I don't
have this but you know if you find
something that you like to do or love to
do be great at it and see if you can
turn it into a business and worst case
you're gonna have fun doing what it is
you love to do in best case you can turn
it into a business I I'm just not big on
excuses I just think if you're really
everybody has that opportunity to go for
it they just kind of do it one of the
things that companies do or startups do
they come up with an idea
they'll Google it and if they don't see
it in the first two pages they think
it's original you've got to go back
right because over the past 15 years
there's so many different businesses
that have tried and failed you have to
go back and find those and learn from
those so you've got to understand all
the implications and you have to learn
from history and so the best advice I
can give you on a video before talking
to you or emailing with you is that
you've got to find out the history of
people who have tried your idea because
there's a 99.99999% chance that your
idea has been tried before that's not a
good reason not to start it because you
might be able to outperform them but you
better learn from the history of your
idea um because you know what they say
about people who don't learn from
history you just watched two amazing
clips with Mark Cuban take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]